hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zum heutigen video
ja man ja heute zu ja heute ich lade
heute etwas hoch was ich schon sehr sehr
lange nicht mehr gemacht habe was
unglaublich ob sie den kommentaren
verlangt wurde leute haben dieses format
fahren willst beerdigt achten ist vorbei
aber nein ich reagiere heute auf eure
videos mal wieder so cool oder
definitiv nein ich habe deswegen gestern
abend auf twitter gepostet bietet videos
ein hashtag luca reagiert wird mal
wieder zeit und da ich das leider erst
um mitternacht gepostet habe kam auch
dementsprechend resonanzen war auf
kinder und mittel noch zu starten die
hamburger schule halt die schnauze
okay ein sorry von disturbing jurist tut
mir leid das geht wieder relativ spät
rausgehauen habe dass die videos zu
wenden sollte aber ich habe gedacht ich
wollte das unbedingt heute hochladen und
es ist ja gerade noch relativ früh und
ich muss gleich noch an die uni und
alles möglich ich glaube es ist gerade
acht uhr dreißig oder 48 oder so am
sorry aber er hat mir sogar ein angebot
gemacht ich geb dir tomatensaft ostern
mit uns in ruhe und wir alle wissen ja
leute wenn es um tomatensaft da macht
man das also okay es tut mir leid ich
hoffe dass meine entschuldigung an in
zukunft werde ich nicht mehr so spät
nach videos fragen
[Musik]
ich versuche mal so zu tanzen wie sie da
ich selber bin meine musik spaß bei dem
video was ich euch jetzt als nächstes
ein blender passiert etwas womit man
wirklich überhaupt nicht rechnen also es
gibt ja diese datenflut challenge wo man
einfach eine flasche mit ein bisschen
wasser dritte mann musste quasi so
schneider und dann drehte sich einmal um
dann steht ihr stellen sich wieder quasi
automatisch hin und dann gibt es
dahingehend noch seine football bartl
flip challenge wo man die flasche auf
einen fußball stellen dann schießt den
fußball weg und die flasche dreht sich
und stellt sich dann wieder auf den
flaschenboden halt hin was bei diesem
video allerdings passiert ist sehr krank
[Musik]
wie sie in gottes namen kriegt man es
hin dass eine flasche sich nicht auf den
boden stellt sondern wieder auf den
deckel
auch sturm mache neben der pacht oder
als das video zum ersten mal gesehen
habe dachte ich mir halt wirklich
einfach nur sorgt jetzt in dem fußballer
weg und dann müsste mal ein ball flüssig
in die flasche steckt tief auf den
verging denke leute ihr seid unfassbar
talentiert die dieses video aufgenommen
gesendet haben am silvester ist vorbei
also ist jetzt ende das heißt feuerwerk
ist derzeit wieder ersten so 350 tagen
gefeiert euch extrem ab weil in der
raketen abschießt er gut okay vielleicht
auch sein kandidat dafür silvester habe
ich in köln am rhein verbracht und ich
bin auch ein bisschen darauf ausgerastet
dass überall auf einmal feuerwerk war ja
ich fand das sehr krass
wisst ihr diese ganze tomatensaft sache
das hat alles irgendwie angefangen weil
es denn mir damals ein video
eingeschickt hat wohl einfach
tomatensaft gesagt hat und dann hab ich
das so gesagt schreibt meine tomaten
kommentare und blabla blauen immer
diesen videos kommen mindestens ein
video wohl irgendjemand tomatensaft sagt
diesmal mir sogar schon zwei automaten
und ich habe tomaten sagt wirklich gerne
getrunken ich war viel unterwegs im
flieger und dadurch mehr tomatensaft
getrunken mit salz und fährt von allen
drin aber seitdem ich so mit tomatensaft
bombardiert werde ich es gar nicht mehr
und immer wenn im supermarkt gehe mit
meinen freunden alle zu hören
in der tat das ist normal enthaltung
zwischen mir meinen freunden bei bay
[Musik]
so wollen wir zusammen club gehen das
vorhin mit yuan der beat wo die so
getanzt hat unsere zwar noch ganz winzig
und so aber sie ist halt einfach so
komplett lustlos sollen wir was wir
machen jetzt mal eine community aktion
das nächste mal wenn ich euch irgendwie
sagen sollte er schickt mir mal videos
ein ich will ein video machen dich
darauf reagiere und so schickte mir alle
tanz videos von euch
okay das heißt ich reagiere auf eure
tanz moves werde damit einverstanden
seid dann schreibt man in die kommentare
tanz
ich hab mir das gerade angeguckt ich hab
das war schon gestern abend gesehen wo
ich das rausgesucht habe aber das ist
einfach so unfassbar walking to all
diesen scheiß ja wirklich die recker
diese reise direkt über die schale und
es juckt es einfach nicht das eis nicht
einfach so straight kompletter neben
dieser traurige tore glatteis und die
schade doch berührt hey leute hier die
wir dann ein gewählt habt ihr habt den
preis dieser folge gewonnen okay ihr
seid in dieser folge will ich die dann
das zwischen besteuerte video
ihr gebildet luftballons an euren hund
und lasst ihn hoch fliegen ich weiß wie
ich jetzt kommen bestimmt so
hundebesitzer an und sagen so ich dir
jetzt das video weil es folge meilen
also mir wird ja auch noch zugesendet
aber ist es in ordnung also bestimmt hat
er den hund danach runtergenommen aber
ich glaube wenn ich von von
irgendwelchen höheren wesen an
luftballons gefällt das nicht cool aber
suite ist es erstmal korrekt dass ihren
sticker habt das heißt sie haben nämlich
was aus dem der minister von de gekauft
was euch auf jeden fall selbst ein paar
gegenüber erscheinen lässt aber mir habt
den halt auf dieses auf welches wort war
das ob das geklappt hat
auf penis in der stadt also leute wenn
irgend jemand von euch erst rosenhöhe
woche war das liegen soll kommt oder aus
der umgebung fahrt dorthin und schaut
auf der spyder noch hängig wert mega
witzig wenn ich dann bei instagram so
bild als ceo der smiley hände oder so
ähnlich wird versucht alles durch zu
leicht wenn überhaupt keiner von euch
aus rosenhöhe oder aus der umgebung
kommen aber das wäre nicht mega witzig
weil zb ich bin letztens aber durch köln
gelaufen und habe an in seiner baustelle
unserem baustellenschild mainz mit
angepackt gewinnen solltest mouvement de
luca du hast gesagt ich soll meinen
laptop fest ist sich war es nicht war
ich ja ich habe wirklich in einer der
letzten videos und vip gesagt ja wenn
ich ins video konferenz der laptop auf
ich weiß genau wenn ich das video
nachher schneider habe ich nicht viel
zeit um meine alten videos durch zu
suchen im schnitt also glaubt es mir
einfach dass erst gesagt hat und jetzt
hat er wirklich ein video anscheinend
hoch geladen wo er seinen laptop
gefressen hat also wir schauen da
einfach mal
ich habe gesagt ich soll meinen laptop
fresse ich muss man gebraucht zweimal
gekommen
danke dafür auf jeden fall aber jetzt
muss ich leider wahrscheinlich hast du
ein laptop da gegessen außerhalb der
kamera und kann kriegt er hat zwar
diesmal nicht als wetteinsatz gesagt
aber leute ich würde einfach mal sagen
wenn dieses video 40.000 likes okay dann
hast du als aufgabe mir das nächste mal
wieder in die sendung wirklich dein
laptop ist im ganzen oder zwei wenn du
groß nun hast
passiert da noch irgendwas
papa video-kamera wirklich also solche
sachen auch schon auf videos wo leute
meinen namen auf dem papier geschrieben
am rausgeschmissen haben oder
aufgegessen megacool feiere ich immer
übertrieben suite community
zusammenhalten längste es geht nicht
bescheuert wenn mein name bot schon
angezählt auf einem blatt papier ein typ
hat seinen laptop gegessen leute tanzen
wie die verrücktesten menschen und dann
so was ein mensch als hund leute ich
glaube ich glaube das war so ein
bisschen der grund warum ich dieses katz
format gar nicht mehr hochgeladen habe
andere youtuber kriegen so intellektuell
hochwertige video einsendungen über
handelt den weltfrieden und über die
amerikanischen wahlen und ich bei mir
essen meine zuschauer gern meinen laptop
mit diesem video haben wir tatsächlich
den den den tiefpunkt vom kompletten
niveau erreicht das ist
das was ihr von mir meine damen und
herren es euch gefallen hat dass man
fetten leichter wenn ihr euch freute
sich dass sie wieder mache und bei was
ich glaube ich gesagt glaube 40.000 live
da muss der laptop presse an wirklichen
laptop essen hier findet ihr in smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf die könnte
meinen channel abonnieren und seit cool
wenn wir nicht gern cool sein hier
findet ihr ein anderes video
eingeblendet klicks an ich meine wenig
zu tun
[Musik]